I'm Alice little and I am a legal sex
worker
hi I'm Lexie Jade and I'm a legal sex
worker today we are answering some of
the most commonly asked questions about
sex work a commonly asked question is if
legal sex workers use protection the
answer is yes we are legally required to
use condoms by law for each and every
sex act and when it comes to going down
on the ladies we have a dental dams
available too so when we're on our
period it's really really simple we just
use black sheets dark towels black
condoms and then a sea sponge or a wet
tampon for just the period of the party
and then removed when finished yeah a
lot of sex workers also will use birth
control that will prevent them from
getting a typical cycle that is when I
choose to do it and it works out really
great there's a huge completion between
forced coerced sex trafficking and sex
work the biggest difference is choice
those of us that choose to enter the
industry do you feel of our own volition
and freedom we retain ownership of our
body is we set our own prices we say no
when we want to it can be in the middle
of a party and I can ask you to leave
and you have to leave everything is our
choice everything goes as far as we want
it it's not to say that there's a right
way and a wrong way to do sex work but I
choose to work out at the legal brothel
system oh yes sex workers pay a lot of
money in taxes this year I will be
paying over six figures in taxes I file
as an LLC much like any other business
would and then I'm able to deduct my
expenses from that Awards there are
quite a few yeah we are independent
contractors at the ranch
that's what allows us to have the
freedom to set our own prices offer the
services that we want we're essentially
all businesses within a business I think
we can only speak for ourselves
yes as a legal sex worker my experience
is going to be very different than those
that are working on the streets I am
offered legal protection there is a
security
and I have a panic button in my room
that I can press if I ever feel the need
because of the legal nature of my
industry it tends to keep away those
that would have ill wishes I generally
feel safe I'm usually treated with a lot
of respect my clientele is really great
yeah there's like a lot of
misconceptions about the people that see
sex workers - how many times I've heard
of clients say I'm not the kind of guy
that usually comes in here and I stop
them and I say well the guys that
usually come in here and spend time with
me are generous and respectful and great
companions so I really hope you are like
a lot of the clients that I see I've
seen everything from CEO of a fortune
500 company to a blue-collar worker that
works with the local Railroad
Association the people who come to see
us aren't seeking to bring violence to
women they're seeking out intimacy which
is a beautiful and healthy thing there
are so many different services that are
offered by legal sex workers the service
that I must get requested for is GFE or
the girlfriend experience where we might
go out for dinner or lunch have a
conversation and it's so much more than
just the sex it's the intimacy of it
they want that act of listening the
companionship and the intimacy an
intellectual beautiful woman on demand
we work with virgins we work with
straight women that have never learned
how to interact with their own bodies in
a pleasurable way I have also worked
with folks that are on the autism
spectrum in teaching them new ways of
communicating and experiencing dating in
a way that's healthiest for that I
really enjoy being a safe place for a
couple to come into and you're unsure
things can go beautifully it literally
can change someone's relationship so
that's been very requested and very
rewarding for me I can kind of step in
as a third party mediator take a look at
what's currently happening in the
relationship and help them troubleshoot
it other couples come in because they
want to have fun they want to have a
third person in their relationship and
certainly aren't in this to steal
someone's husband yeah to be clear like
the idea of us stealing your husband's
is the same as child care providers
trying to steal your kids that's just
not happening I definitely get
satisfactions actually for my job that's
a given I allow myself to enjoy it
whatever happens happens I usually have
a great time it's a very rewarding job
you're getting to make these amazing
intimate connections with somebody so I
always encourage people to lean into
their fantasies and their desires and
actually put their pleasure first in
that equation I like to enable them to
do that that is so true it is the time
to be selfish and ask exactly for what
you want decree upon it and like live
out your fantasy
[Music]
something that I'd really like people to
know about legal sex workers it's
something that we choose to do because
we're looking for that safety net of
having the legalization unfortunately
legal sex work only exists in Nevada it
comes it oftentimes a great personal
expense the ladies are required to get
themselves to the ranch location pay for
their doctor pay for their sheriff's
card and so there is a certain cost
investment involved when becoming a
legal sex worker for me a big
misconception with legal sex work we're
doing something bad we're hurting you
your families ourselves our children
it's nothing more than two people coming
together and appreciating each other
hear from us firsthand and not what you
think or from a movie talk to us not
about us we have medical professionals
to take care of health care needs we
have child care providers to take care
of child care needs
we have mental health professionals to
take care of our mental health needs
spiritual leaders to take care of our
spiritual needs
why not sex workers to take care of our
sex needs that's what we do we take care
of that need you're welcome
[Music]